let's talk about this uh this very
obvious article from timcast.com the
headline should be just duh but it's um
half of democrats and seventy percent of
all voters say inflation is affecting
their family budget
pollsters and i citizen asked voters if
the current rate of inflation is
affecting your family budget and yes
broken down by gender male and female
responses were nearly identical with
74.5 percent of men and 74.6 of women
saying yes
amazing when looking at location all
regions of the country had almost
identical responses clearly inflation is
having a very broad impact across the
country irrespective of who you are how
old you are where you live what your
politics are and the level of your
education
so
subhead duh in this article but why is
it
why is it getting worse why is it that
it seems to be only the republicans are
like hey stop spending and the democrats
are like spend more
well that's because there's a big
transfer of wealth and people extorting
a national tragedy for their personal
benefit and the benefit of their friends
in the multinational corporations that
are robbing this country blind as of
course it's a sinking ship that's going
down very dramatically fast and before
kovid there was one person worth over
100 billion dollars now there's
nine ten of the richest people before
covet were worth 695 billion dollars now
they're worth
1.36 trillion dollars let's take let's
let's think about that for a real quick
second
do we think the lockdowns are going to
get worse i vote yes yeah yeah um it
could go either way i think there's a
probability that
uh omnicron could be the best case
scenario and could be the end of this
there's a possibility there's a
possibility they exploit the
transvisibility and say it's getting
worse so i think it'll get worse what do
you think do you think you vote worse or
better
i'm right on the razor's edge there it's
really hard to say yeah uh
white pill it's going to get better it's
going to get better yeah so then you
want to short amazon
that's why i'm on the edge here i'm not
trying to give any stock advice the
stock market is a positive scheme yeah
yeah i'm saying that the the the royal
you we whatever yeah an individual
if if it is going to get better you want
to short
amazon stock because people are going to
start shopping other businesses will
start popping up there'll be competition
but if it's going to get worse amazon
stock is going to keep going through the
roof modernist stock pfizer stock so you
too can be a billionaire just like
you know these these these big tech
moguls and everything like that who who
bought a bunch of this stock nancy
pelosi just just invest in what she
invests in she knows what's up right
what is she investing in we should have
a stock ticker of everything she's she's
doing every single day just so we can
see what's going on there just to kind
of like call it out even more but it's
pretty crazy what's happening in the
financial world because like we know
it's bad but it's a lot worse than we're
even being told right now and shocking
the levels of money that's just being
printed with the touch of a button and
how much of that money is going into
private hands like blackrock roblox
pelosi's got 10 000 shares in roblox
what
she's got crowdstrike
that's not surprising what's crowdstrike
crowdstrike uh it's a security let me
make sure i can read it very
specifically as to what they say it is
crowdstrike provides cloud-based
software using security of computers
servers and mobile phones the stock
pulled a bit back blah blah blah
crowdstrike was just
i don't i want to be careful for legal
reasons but very much associated with a
lot of the stories about democrats and
i do remember that yeah right right
right
let's see what else they got they got uh
she's she got a tesla what does she have
she has uh mandatory funds in january
show pelosi exercised 25 call options on
tesla
um let's see is that there we go
nvidia
really interesting nvidia netflix that
seems like a a no-brainer and is that
all is that all six but you gotta
continue oh you gotta click to continue
what is this insider monkey paypal oh
oh here we go now it's going to do the
thing apple she got apple what else she
got she got alphabet
she's got microsoft
and she's got facebook
i mean she's betting on big tech no
she's betting on lockdowns yeah she is
nancy pelosi everything she bought there
some of them are obvious but she's
invested in companies that are very
important for lockdowns computer
security yes
well i'm not super worried i'm not
saying like literally everything but the
stuff she's invested in these big tech
companies
what are people going to be doing under
lockdown they're going to be using
computers they're going to be on
facebook alphabet google
apple inc they're going to be watching
netflix you got to get them in the
metaverse
paypal is going to be digital uh
transactions
right so i'm not saying that's that's
evidence of of you know necessarily
nvidia what does nvidia do do you guys
know what video does graphics gpus okay
so you're gonna be having people play
video games yeah she's it's metaverse
baby so let's place bets about tesla
electric cars
crowd strike is just you know whatever
roblox
roblox the the wondertail stories of
children's books and infinite
possibilities of stories and worlds well
i don't know about that one but
putting kids more in video games
metaphor stuff i'm not saying all of
this is definitive proof that she's very
much like on board with metaverse or
whatever but she's certainly invested in
companies that would be involved in a
metaverse like reality
or a lockdown reality
or you know the future of of pod living
the future of uh the metaverse she
doesn't have any bug companies does she
no wouldn't it be surprising i don't
think it would be that on the nose that
obviously a little on the nose hold on a
minute you guys we know
what these people want to do right yep
you will own nothing and you'll be happy
yup what kind of company could we start
or invest in that works perfectly for
people who own nothing a sharing company
a what sharing company you share your
devices you share your clothes equipment
you share your clothes and what do they
want us to eat
so we should start bug farms dude we'll
be rich
i'll start we'll start we'll start a
farm no a cicada farm oh
my my soul wouldn't be able to to live
with that yeah
just thinking about that it's capitalism
baby yeah you know where they're going
and you know the best part is they'll
probably subsidize it the government
will be alive this is in line with our
plans here's free money to run your
business
and then you can sell all the grubs and
and roaches
and uh i wonder if roly polies taste
good oh i guess pill bugs find out
aren't we there's way too much
they can figure it out you sprinkle it
on your bug cream like fungus ice cream
that doesn't have to be good it just has
to sustain you to the point where you
can you know live a little bit i think
it's just going to be goo just like in
the matrix and you know and either it's
just injected into your veins or into
the back of your head or that was kind
of that was kind of dumb though because
they they if they could just plug you
into your own mini matrix like they were
doing with neo and then you could eat a
buffet yeah and enjoy yourself you know
what i mean and i like how they're like
the brain makes it real that's stupid
the brain makes it real so what happens
if you eat a whole cake will your body
like vomit in real life there's nothing
to vomit up bile i guess
but they had to otherwise it was just
like
you know you wouldn't die in the matrix
so you know speaking of the matrix
matrix is coming out very soon in a few
hours in a few hours one oh yeah yeah on
hbo next on hbo max 3 a.m eastern 3 a.m
eastern interesting is what they're
saying are you going to watch it uh i
might just wake up just to see it
i'm a huge matrix fan
but i i do believe this is going to be
the end of the kind of real matrix
trilogy and the introduction of the new
world order matrix trilogy that goes
along with the propaganda and narrative
and talking points of all the bull crap
that's already being shoved down our
throats that's how i see it i'm a little
pessimistic on that um but i still want
to see it because i'm a big fan of the
of the trilogy i remember when the first
movie came out i was just like whoa this
is insane i remember watching it and be
like there's so many like
representations things you know society
you know be the funniest thing ever if
in the new matrix there's a scene
where like neo is like you know like in
the trailer he's eating all the blue
pills and then he's like i gotta clear
my head so then he's like i'm gonna go
to the movies and he goes to a movie
there's a huge line of people and
there's agents scanning vax passports
and he's like what's this is the matrix
and then they're like you know just like
jabbing at all the people who did yeah i
already did i already did one video
about my kind of theory about what was
going to be happening uh in the matrix
on my platform but i i people are
calling it the woke tricks and i think
they're going to be yeah they're going
to be like neo you weren't really the
one it's this blue-haired person that
has all the power non-binary yeah
it's the latest it was the one the whole
time and even if it is
even if it is
okay but but don't make it where you
have to shove it down people's throats
like you can make a character that's you
know whatever you want them to be but
when you overtly try to push a political
message and you stop worrying about the
the kind of entertainment value of it
that's when it just gets annoying
because like we could see the
subconscious propaganda the subliminal
messages you're putting on there but
when you're trying to make it like overt
for like
right right people who are not
intelligent it's just angry no the issue
is people who are lacking talent making
movies that's what it really is they're
ideologues and they have no talent
because you watch the new ghostbusters
compared to girl busters the new
ghostbusters the the new team these four
kids you've got a boy a girl you've got
an asian kid and and and a black you
know girl yeah it's a completely diverse
cast of young people who put on the
jumpsuits but there's no like overt you
know the white man and like patriarchy
it was literally just
they happen to be people and they're
ghost busting girl busters was literally
like a bunch of really angry
stereotypical nasty dudes and like
you know these mary sue characters doing
slapstick comedy talk about really awful
yeah yeah and again most most
entertainment is propaganda it's it's
used for uh
weaponized political purposes it's been
for a very long time that's why the cia
is so interconnected with hollywood
that's why the cia is literally out
there promoting uh black panther and
other another kind of movies out there
that fit their narrative they're writing
scripts in many instances with the
military industrial complex giving
a lot of movies and hollywood studios
favors to use a lot of their equipment
in exchange for rewriting their scripts
and always making them the good guys no
matter what the situation is they're
also rewriting this they also rewrite
the scripts for the benefit of china um
so many times in so many egregious ways
disney made a movie just trying to
appease just china in itself and to see
this layer of intervention when
something is supposed to be
entertainment something is supposed to
be peer something is supposed to be
just something that's going to inspire
you but it's used to re-educate you it's
used to change your line of thinking
it's it's it's horrible to see because a
lot of people unsuspectingly see it and
they get influenced by it sure but i
don't i don't really care all much about
that what i care about is bad content
you know the problem with captain marvel
the problem with these these overtly
political
movies and stuff is it's just bad
content it's in it's mean it's insulting
in many ways it's off-putting right one
of the things i brought up with like the
captain marvel film is that she
literally robs a guy like she's not a
good person he
he tells her to smile so she steals his
clothes
and i'm just like it's kind of
villainous behavior i can't root for her
you know and so they think they're
making this powerful statement where she
like tells the man because he said smile
and i'm like
the heroes are supposed to be like i
will not be dragged into your petty bs
so the issue is just bad content you
make a film with the female protagonist
hunger games i thought hunger game was
fantastic oh look it's a female hero you
know what i mean first one but then you
end up with these movies like captain
marvel or girl busters and it's just
annoying
not good like like i was saying with
ghostbusters the new one diverse cast
for the for the new ghostbusters i don't
care cool it's just a bunch of kids it
was funny the little podcast kid he was
great but the content was there that's
the main thing yeah the new ghostbusters
yeah yeah paul rudd was hilarious yeah
it always is uh for the most part so is
the original matrix and and that
original series
propaganda does it qualifies propaganda
or is it just too entertaining to be
propaganda well there's a lot of
parallels to our current society that a
lot of people could make their kind of
own understandings of and their their
own kind of guesses to what it really is
in their kind of life form so i think
just that as an art form in itself is is
pretty rare and unique where you could
say oh this is you know an explanation
for this in our society and you could
have so many different explanations i
thought that was great but it was
predominantly still focused on you know
central controllers you being a battery
you being a slave you fighting the
people who are central controllers who
were extorting robbing you of your life
i thought that overall message like like
a lot of you know you know messages out
there was overall somewhat of a very
intriguing one that that was thought
provoking um instead of just beating you
over the head of a propaganda uh there's
propaganda everywhere everything's
propaganda isn't it isn't it better to
be in the matrix
that's what oblivious some people would
argue
i would i would totally disagree with
you
it's like being an ostrich with your
head in the sand and you're in your butt
all the way out there ready for some
top-notch globalists to come in and do
unspeakable
uh
things with you so i prefer not to have
my head in sand i like having my but
let's let's think about this swivel
how would you feel
if all of a sudden you woke up
in this weird room and your whole life
was fake
and you have no idea where you are yeah
that'd be crazy right yeah like what
would you think you know i was wild that
was crazy
no you'd be freaking out you'd be like
where am i what's going on you'd be like
my name is luke and i run a youtube
channel and then they're going to come
in they're like no you don't that was
never real
you were in the matrix bro my identity
what it comes down to for me is like in
which okay whether i'm in the matrix or
not in the matrix because i was in the
matrix for a long time just totally
dialed out to everything that was
happening so i understand the the the
sort of you know
goofy sense of peace that you feel when
you're in the matrix but i guess i've
need to know where i'm going to feel the
most sense of purpose
do i feel a sense of purpose in the
matrix or am i useless or do i feel a
sense of purpose outside of the matrix
and seeing what's really happening or
not like that's what it would come down
to for me where's the sense of purpose i
think the matrix if you were in the
matrix it would be hell everything would
be perfect you would always have steak
and i think that's life that's not the
most necessarily yeah no the matrix they
literally say that the first iteration
was perfect and they were people
rejected it so they created an im you
know a more realistic version with
suffering and humans accepted it but i'm
more using it as an example if you would
put yourself in the matrix where you
would get everything you wanted um and
and if you would get everything you
would wanted you would be miserable in
my perspective that's the
argument know
maybe let's let's let's say this
in in base reality luke is
a an overweight
short unattractive
lay about with no ambition and no drive
to fix himself so he enters his own
private you know zuckerverse you know
using the the brain app and it blocks
out memories of your real life so that
you live a life where you earn all of
these things and it just so happens it
comes to you
you'd be very happy you'd be like look
at all my success you wouldn't realize
it was pre-programmed to make you
successful you'd be happy with where you
are you'd think you'd achieved it you
would need barriers of of success you
would need to work for it in order to
get it because if you were just given it
you wouldn't appreciate it but if you
had to struggle sacrifice work hard put
some blood sweat and tears into it yes
yeah and if there's a simulation that
does that that's crazy no i'm look in in
world of warcraft for instance you got
to put in the hours if you want to grind
for that you know legendary or epic gear
so yeah you'd play a game it would be
let's put it this way in the real world
you know when you go out into a field
and you fight wild boars you're not very
successful with just a small dagger like
you would be in world of warcraft you
can run up to a hundred wild boars you
know at the start of warcraft if you're
playing human alliance or whatever and
you just walk up and go like
the board dies go up to a wild boar in
in the real world and see what happens
the point is video games make this a
challenge and there's there's grinding
but it's so easy my point is you could
be in the matrix and you think you're
struggling man this video game can be
hard sometimes but come on imagine
fighting a real grizzly bear it's crazy
for all you know you're in this this
matrix because you're a layabout loser
and you wanted an easy version of life
we could be literally in the metaverse
right now
in a sense i believe we are and like the
whole goal of the metaverse is to like
program people to love zuckerberg
so like that's the only way to escape
the simulation is to finally accept
zuckerberg into your heart and then you
wake up and go like where am i
and then there's a big picture of mark
right in front of you like i love you
and then there's like those two doctors
and like congratulations
you've escaped the simulation
there's that comic i love it where it's
a guy and he's holding the silica gel oh
my gosh and it says do not eat and he
goes those those big wigs the silica gel
factory can't tell me what to do when he
eats it and the next one is him waking
up and there's two scientists saying
congratulations you've escaped the
simulation
can't tell me what to do
yeah don't don't eat those don't do that
yeah don't they're not good what if uh
uh you know cause we talk a lot about
religion and stuff what if what if
we're like reality is effectively a
simulation but it's a sorting algorithm
the people who are everyone's born into
a matrix and then everyone lives a life
in the matrix and then only certain
people who have certain attributes are
the ones who actually get to come out of
it and go back to base reality what if
it's effectively like some kind of
human development chamber for you know
new humans or whatever what if after you
live your life you wake up from the
matrix but you're a baby
that is that's just real you're like
and they're like you've lived a full
life and now you're a baby now you can
apply all that wisdom and knowledge into
a new life in base reality except for
the reincarnation aspect of that the
attack down there at the end i think
that's almost certainly the case it has
reincarnation no no
accepting that part not that yeah all
right thanks no no reincarnation but
we're almost certainly living in a
matrix like when you're born they put
you in the matrix and then
program your brain to experience like 80
years of life
and then it happens in the span of like
three months as a baby so you're like
all the babies are just like regular
people walking around and being like
whoa i'm a baby again and then like you
but you grow up and you have all that
knowledge from a full life that would be
an effective society wouldn't it
sort of i guess
but but if only some people made it out
of the matrix then you'd have a very
homogenized culture because the matrix
are effectively choosing which humans
could come out of it you know well i
mean that's the dichotomy of heaven and
hell it's two different homogenized
cultures
yeah what if like when you die if you're
like you qualify for hell it just ejects
you into a sewer pipe and if you qualify
for heaven like a metal arm picks you up
and like puts you in like a bed
certainly and then you're like you know
some people accidentally get woken up to
it and they're like ah this is terrible
and they tell everybody and they're like
i saw a crazy light and it was fire and
it was awful i was like well yeah that
was the meat grinder bro
it was just dropping your brain
yeah luke's eyes just lit up
i'm looking at it
into like a multi-dimensions and uh all
these other energetic fields i think
there's you know a lot of things that we
don't understand i don't think we're
supposed to understand them and i think
we should be okay with that um and not
try to always you know try to see i i
need to i need to know this maybe we
don't need to know it maybe you know i
think it's better if we don't
you know oh yeah i mean there's a lot of
ambiguity there but i think that there's
something to be said for the human
spirit and i think that you basically
have a certain amount of time dedicated
to a human shell a corporeal form and
then beyond that the spirit is liberated
to one side of the matrix or the other i
mean that almost certainly has to be the
case i really believe that well you have
a choice in life you could go through
the very you know
the light side or the dark side the the
love or evil i think there are two big
kind of energetic forces out there and
if you give your life to one it's going
to propel you in that kind of direction
um and and you have a lot of choices you
have a lot of discernment you have a lot
of very tough decisions to make in this
life and i think those decisions will be
with you as an energetic force forever
because energy cannot be destroyed nor
created only transferred so what you
decide to do in this life is is up to
you but uh you know
you're giving a lot of different choices
you could either be on the side of evil
or good i choose good i try to and my
interpretations and understanding of
that and i try to do as as much good as
i can and if that's not the case then
what's the point of character yeah
what's the point of developing character
and then like maintaining character
yeah i can't think of one i can't think
of one either yeah how do you define
good
um
basic understanding of of uh not hurting
people helping people um and
respecting their bodily autonomies
respecting their human rights this
respecting their in in in in sorry i
can't even say this correctly
inalienable right there we go i got that
out out there and i think not forcing
people to do something
or
or
hurting people for your benefit is the
other side of it i agree with all of
that but i'll offer a simpler definition
good is truth
bad is lies there you go simple yeah i
like that there's truth and there's lies
what if like your mom asks you if she's
fat
you should just tell her yeah you're fat
mom you should be honest with her i mean
it's not necessarily i don't know i i
don't know what if she agrees with that
question in the context of good truth
and bad lies
like so but
i understand what you're saying yeah
like what if what if what if there's
like you know you know you're you're
your mom buys a new dress and you think
it's tacky and she's like how do you
like my new dress i saved up what i'm so
excited and you're gonna be like it's
tacky and gross i hate it or are you
gonna be like i will lie and say i like
it because it's important to her well
there is one school of thought that
suggests that truth always pierces and
it always hurts you know there are lies
that are thin wispy skins and there is
truth which is always a dart and it's
always painful otherwise it wouldn't be
truth so there is something to be said
for truth in that moment but there's
also something to be said for what is
your mother's state is your mother in a
state of mind where this piece of truth
could just pierce her and destroy her
can you think of a circumstance in which
truth feels good
yeah not to somebody that is
being lied to yes right because it could
jar them like a sleepwalker yeah yeah
because i was gonna say like truth can
feel good but
if the truth is something like i baked
cookies it's like sure that's just like
a thing you did you know what i mean but
truth we're typically referring to like
snapping someone out of the lies like
telling them about what's going on and
people typically do not react well to it
well my i guess i would reanalyze re and
no i i don't know how to say that but i
guess i would reframe it like this like
you bake cookies and you give them to
somebody
you know it's just like i made these for
you
like i mean that's that's in a sense a
kind of truth sharing you know it's just
like it's it's thoughtfulness
it's it's something outside of truth but
it also is in the same spirit of what i
would call truth if that makes any sense
at all
i'm like you're fat and that dress is
tacky
give me some cupcakes i'm hungry
but but you know there's no i think i
think good is creation and
evil is destruction but within evil
there is some good and within good there
is some evil of course
what i mean by that is we want to create
more we want more people we want people
to grow and flourish we want to develop
we want to invent we want to explore we
want to expand we want to create complex
systems by bringing energy together and
then organizing it and bad is when
people just destroy it but sometimes you
need to destroy in order to create so if
the ultimate goal is creation there
could be some destruction it's not
inherently evil and if the ultimate goal
is destruction sometimes there's
creation and that creation is evil as
well so for example you're like i want
to destroy everything so i'm going to
make a new method of destroying
everything it's like okay you're doing
bad things and you might be saying i
want to create things but i have to tear
down that machine that's destroying
everything so there is some destruction
right yin yang yeah without no evil
there's no love without love there's no
evil so this touches on something that
jordan peterson analyzes in depth i mean
it's just like too much order is
totalitarianism yeah it's nazi germany
too much chaos is a school shooting you
know and you can't you can't have too
much without being able to balance it
out for some sort of harmony to emerge
freedom too is also uh an aspect of love
of truth that is also a very important
virtue of that positive energetic force
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you